حذر مدير وكاله الاستخبارات المركزيه
الامريكيه مايك بومبيو من ان ايران تقترب
من تحقيق الهلال الشيعي في الشرق الاوسط
وكشف بومبو عن استراتيجيه امريكيه لمواجهه
ما سماه تهديد ايران وتعديات في المنطقه
التي قال انها زادت بعد الاتفاق النووي
الموقع معها عام
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ونناقش فيما
وراءه ما مدى جديه الانزعاج الذي تبديه
واشنطن من السياسات الايرانيه في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط وباهي الحدود التي يمكن ان
تذهب اليها الولايات المتحده للحد مما
تصفه بتهديدات طهران
[موسيقى]
وتعديات بين يدي جوله ستحمل وزير الدفاع
الامريكي جيمس ماتيس الى خمس دول في الشرق
الاوسط خرج مدير وكاله الاستخبارات
المركزيه الامريكيه سي اي اي مايك بومبيو
بتحضر شديد اللهجه مما سماه تهديدات ايران
وتعديات في الشرق الاوسط والتي اقتربت بها
حسب بومبيو من اكمال هلال شيعي يمثل
نفوذها ويعمل على خدمته تحذيرات رجل
الاستخبارات الامريكي الاول تاتي في سياق
يبدو رؤيه جديده لواشنطن تجاه نشاط طهران
في المنطقه وما يجب القيام به للحد من هذا
النشاط تقرير ناصر اي
طهر فهم امريكي مختلف او ربما اعمق لما
بات تسميه واشنطن الخطر الايراني ليس من
فراغ استدعاء واشنطن لمصطلح الهلال الشيعي
وذاك حلم ايراني قديم جديد لا يراه رجل
الاستخبارات الاول في الولايات المتحده في
مصلحه بلده لكن طهران كما يقول مدير السي
اي اي تقترب من
تحقيقه يذكر مدير وكاله الاستخبارات
المركزيه بان الايرانيين طوروا القدره
الصاروخيه لحزب الله اللبناني كما ان لهم
ميليشيات شيعيه في العراق وهم يدعمون ايضا
الحوثيين الذين يقول ان صواريخهم تصل الى
السعوديه لكن الم تكن الصواريخ الامريكيه
على قاعده الشعيرات السوريه ام القنابل
التي القيت في افغانستان حماله رسائل الى
دول واطراف عده بينها ايران هي كما راها
البعض رسائل حزم وجزم ايضا بان في
الولايات المتحده اداره جديده لها مقاربه
جديده للسياسه الخارجيه والاهم انها لا
تتردد في استخدام القوه لحمايه مصالحها
فكيف اذا تعلق الامر بما يصفها الامريكيون
باكبر دوله راعيه للارهاب لكن ماذا لو
اخفقت خطوات واشنطن العسكريه المباغته
الاخيره في اقناع الايرانيين باعاده النظر
في مشروعهم التوسعي وتمددهم الاقليمي بد
للمسؤولين الامريكيين ان ما يصفونه بتعدي
طهران قد زادت بشكل درامي منذ توقيع
الاتفاق النووي مع الغرب عام
2015 معروف موقف اداره ترامب من ذلك
الاتفاق لكن يصعب توقع طريقه تعاطيه مع
مالته ثمت في واشنطن من لا يزال يؤمن
بفاعليه العقوبات الاقتصاديه وثمه من يرى
ان من الخيارات ما يحتاج دعما دوليا
والشاهد ان للقوه هامشا واسعا في نقاشات
دوائر صنع القرار الامريكي وذاك هامش
كالذي يعتقد محللون ان رئيس ترامب على غير
داب سلفه يتركه للمؤسسه العسكريه انه
واياها يعودون الى حلفائهم الاستراتيجيين
الذين خذل اوباما كثيرا منهم ذهب وزير
الدفاع جيمس ماتس للتحرك نحو الشرق الاوسط
في جوله فهمت صحف ومواقع رسميه ايرانيه
انها جوله خاصه بايران ليس فهما خاطئه
فالبنت جون لا يخفي ان التركيز في محطات
السعوديه ومصر واسرائيل وقطر وجيبوتي
سيكون على رص التحالفات العسكريه ومواجهه
مخاطر زعزعه الاستقرار هي اذا محاوله لوضع
استراتيجيه تصد لطهران استراتيجيه تعتمد
بدايه
على التعاون مع الشركاء الاقليميين
يتقدمهم الخليجيون لكنها تستوعب ايضا
اسرائيل والاوروبيين ممن تقول واشنطن انهم
يشعرون بتهديد ايران عن اي تهديد تتحدثون
ترد ايران الرسميه يقول ساستها ان الخطر
الحقيقي هو التطرف والارهاب اما ما دون
ذلك فمجرد رهاب من ايران مفتعل ومحاولات
للايقاع بين
المسلمين
موضوع حلقتنا اليوم نناقشه مع ضيوفنا من
فيرجينيا عبر سكايب مايكل ديل روسو كبير
الباحثين في مركز السياسه الامنيه من
طهران الدكتور حسن احمد يان استاذ دراسات
الشرق الاوسط في جامعه طهران وهنا معنا في
الاستديو ماجد التركي الاكاديمي والمحلل
السياسي السعودي ورئيس مركز الاعلام
والدراسات العربيه الروسيه اهلا بضيوفي
وابدا بالسيد روسو ضيفي من واشنطن فيما
يتعلق
بهذه التحذيرات الامريكيه ما مدى جديه هذه
التحذيرات الامريكيه هذه المره عندما
تتحدث عن تسارع في اكتمال ما وصفته بانه
هلال
شيعي قد يكون الاشخاص
ربما قد استسلموا الى نوع من الاستسلام في
عهد اوباما لكن تاريخيا فان ودفاعا عن
مصالحنا كنا جدين دائما في ان نكون على
علاقه وديه مع
القوى المؤثره
في قبل 30 عاما كان هنالك الكثير من
الشيوعيين
في معسكر الشيوعي كانوا عدائيين جدا معنا
وكنا نريد ان نعقد وقد اظهر التاريخ
ان اننا قمنا بمواجهه هذه التحيات وقمنا
بانظمه بانظمه اسلحه كانت ستهدف جميع
اعدائنا اعتقد ان امريكا
كروسيا هم قوى
نافذه سيد
روسو سيد روسو ما وصفته بانه تراخي من قبل
الاداره السابقه هل كان تراخي اتفاق الرجل
الاول على مستوى الاستخبارات يقول بان
هناك تسارع في وتيره تمدد هذا الهلال
الشيعي بعد الاتفاق
النووي ان طهران منذ الثوره
الاسلاميه كانت تصدر
الارهاب عالميا هنالك الالاف من القوات في
سوريا تدعم نظاما قاسيا الاسد وساهمت في
الحاق الموت
والتدمير
الالاف خاصه من القوى القوى
العسكريه الامريكيه في العراق وايضا
ودعمها لحزب الله
الذي
ايضا ساعدت في
دعم قدرات حزب الله وايضا كان هنالك في
جنوب في امريكا الجنوبيه هنالك وجود شيعي
قوي وهو يمثل تهديدا ليس للقوى الغربيه في
امريكا بل هو تهديد ل جيرانها من
السنه وهي تقوم بعملي زعزعه الاستقبال في
شمال افريقيا وسوريا وايضا طموحاتها
النوويه ان الرئيس احمد دي نجاد الذي
الرئيس السابق ويتحدث الان هو عن الترشيح
للرئاسه كان واضحا تماما عندما تسلم
السلطه في سنه 2005 انه ليس هذه هي الحاله
سيدي الروسو دعني اسال دون الولايات
المتحده وهو امر ممكن
وان واعتذر ب دعني اسال ضيفي من طهران
الدكتور حسن احمدي فيما يتعلق ب رد الفعل
الايراني حتى الان تعقيبا على ما جاء على
لسان رئيس الاستخبارات الامريكيه بان هذه
اسطوانه مشروخه وتكرار لكلام قد قيل من
قبل من قبل الاداره الامريكيه هل ترى
طهران في هذه التصريحات مجرد تكرار لتصريح
حات انتقاديه من قبل واشنطن لسلوك ايران
في المنطقه ام ان الوضع قد تغير في عهد
الرئيس
ترامب طبعا مساء
الخير في ايران طبعا
الرؤيه الرسميه يعني كما جاء كما تفضلت هي
انه لا يوجد جديد هناك يعني اتهامات توجه
لايران الضيه انه هناك افتراض رئيس انه
نفوذ ايران الاقليمي ودورها الاقليمي قد
تزايد بعد توقيع الاتفاق النووي وهذا يعني
هو افتراض لا اعتقد انه صائب لانك يعني
نعود ونسال ما الذي تغير مثلا بعد الاتفاق
النووي لذلك هي هي اتهامات هي هي اتهامات
تتبلور بشكل تدريجي وتاتي في سياق سياسه
قد تكون مستح حدثه لانه حتى الان الرئيس
ترامب لم يبلور او لم يطرح اي
رؤيا تجاه ايران والشرق الاوسط رؤيه
متماسكه واضحه المعالم قد يكون هذا جزء من
بدايات سياسه مختلفه لكن حتى الان لم ارى
يعني في طهران لا اعتقد انه هناك من يرى
انه هناك شيء جديد ا كلها اتهامات والى
الان يعني السياسه الامريكيه كما هي حتى
وان كانت اتهامات سيد احم ديان اشاره رجل
الاستخبارات الى ما جرى في مطار الشعيرات
وكذلك استعمال ام القنابل في افغانستان
وفهم بشكل مباشر انها ايضا رسائل موجهه
لاكثر من طرف يتجاوز سوريا ويتجاوز
افغانستان الى دول مثل ايران وكوريا
الشماليه الم يتغير الضع حتى مع هذه
الرساله لا طبعا هذا تفسير اسرائيلي يعني
رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو قال انه هي رسائل
موجهه الى ايران ولكي لا يحدد ذلك بايران
قال كوريا الشماليه ايضا طبعا هناك
استعراض للقوه في سوريا وفي افغانستان
وطبعا هذه رسائل ايضا قد تكون موجهه
لايران ولروسيا ايضا لكن
اي ان كان استعراض
القوه جزءا من السياسه الامريكيه فايران
يعني بشكل عام قد فاتت
مرت بهذه الحقبه ان تستعرض امامها القوه
لتغير سياستها وهذا واضح الاتفاق النووي
لم ياتي نتاج استعراض القوه في افغانستان
والعراق او غير ذلك نتاج وصول ايران الى
بان لا تغير في سلوك ايران بعد الاتفاق
النو اسال ضيفي هنا في الاستديو ماجد
التركي اذا ايران لا ترى تغيرا في سلوكها
عقب
الاتفاق النووي وان لا شيء تغير في لغه
الاداره الامريكيه باتجاه طهران وبالتالي
الامور على حالها مساء الخير مساء النور
انا في رايي ان عمليه اختزال الفعل
الايراني في في دعم الارهاب هذا خطا خطا
في حق ايران لان يجب ان ان ان نضع الامور
في نصابها الاشكاليه مع ايران هي في تصدير
الثوره منذ 1979 الى الان الارهاب هو ذراع
ووسيله واحده من وسائل ايران في تصدير هذه
الثوره لذلك فقط ان ان نحصر ايران في ان
اشكالنا معها فقط في انها راعيه للارهاب
هذا حقيقه تحجيم للخطر الايراني في
المنطقه هي الخطر الايراني هو في تصدير
الثوره في تصدير المشروع الايراني الذي
قامت عليه ثوره
1979 والتي ضحت ايران حتى بالداخل
الايراني من اجل تحقيق اهداف هذه الثوره
هنا يجب التعامل مع ايران قضيه الارهاب
نعم هو احد الوسائل واحد الوسائل الفاعله
حتى ام القنابل حينما القيت في افغانستان
هي رساله لايران لان ان ايران هي متمركزه
في افغانستان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اداره اوباما كما سلمت العراق لايران هي
سلمت افغانستان الهلال الشيعي ليس هلالا
شيعيا نحن كذلك نختزل الجغرافيا الاقليميه
لايران هو خط يمتد من مزار شريف في
افغانستان مرورا بطاجيكستان في اسيا
الوسطى الى العراق الى الى الى سوريا لذلك
الهلال الشيعي هو تحول الى مستطيل شيعي
نفوذ كامل في المنطقه العربيه جنوب جنوب
لبنان سوريا العراق التغيير الديموغرافي
الممنهج يعني نحن بدانا نتجاهل ونتناسى
التغيير الديموغرافي في جنوب العراق تغيير
الديمقرا وكن اعذرني استاذ ماجد طهران في
ردها على تصريحات المسؤول الامني الامريكي
قالت بان هذه التصريحات والتصعيد منها
الهدف احداث بلبله بين ايران وجيرانها
العرب لمزيد من الاضطراب ومزيد من سوء
العلاقه وان ايران لم تفعل لم تفعل كما
قال ايضا ضيفي قبل قليل من طهران ما
يستدعي كل هذا الخوف منها في المنطقه
وبالتالي احدث اي تكتلات ضدها شوف استاذ
الكريم قضيه علاقه ايران مع جيرانها في
المنطقه هي متوتره يعني هذه علاقه لم
تستقر الا فتره وجيزه في مرحله خاتمي
واحنا نعتبرها مرحله التقاط الانفاس
الايرانيه من اجل اعاده تقديم المشروع
الايراني من جديد في المنطقه الواقع على
الارض العراق سوريا لبنان اليمن البحرين
كله يشهد حقيقه بعبث ايراني حتى عمليه الس
الامريكي لتحجيم ايران ورفع نفوذ ايران من
سوريا او لبنان او تقليله في لبنان ورفعه
من العراق هو لن يحل المشكله لان ايران
زرعت في هذه المناطق بؤر ارهابيه القضيه
ليست قضيه التحرير السلوك السياسي
الاقليمي من السيطره الايرانيه بل النظر
في في اشكاليه ما زرعته ايران ايران زرعت
بؤر طائفيه خلقت بؤر ارهابيه كونت حقيقه
ميليشيات على الارض سواء ميليشيات قاسم
سليماني في العراق والتي امتدت الى سوريا
و حزب الله الذي قدم من من لبنان حزب الله
يعتبر من القوه الضاربه الان صاروخيا
ويمتلك عدد من الالاف من الصواريخ التي
تهدد امن المنطقه لا تهدد امن اسرائيل لا
يعننا اسرائيل اطلاقا اسرائيل هي خصم
استراتيجي لنا في المنطقه واسرائيل مكفيه
الامن من خلال من خلال الحضور الامريكي
والرعايه الامريكيه والاوروبيه لاسرائيل
ولكن على المستوى امن الاقليمي ايران هي
التهديد الاول والرئيسي لسببين الحضور
العسكري والمشروع الثوري ط اذا كانت ايران
بهذه الصوره الصوره ضيفي مايكل ديل روسو
اذا كانت الاداره الامريكيه ايضا جاده في
وقف هذا التغول كما تقوله لايران في
المنطقه ما الخطوات التي تؤكد بان اداره
الرئيس ترامب جاده في كبح جماح هذا
الاندفاع الايراني في
المنطقه بدايه من الجيدي ان نرى انتخابات
ديمقراطيه في ايران كل شيء يتم التخطيط له
في ايران
وساكون راغبا بمعرفه لماذا يرغب السيد
احمد نجاد بالترشيح مره اخرى عندما قال
انه لن يقوم ذلك في الحقيقه لا اعطي قيمه
كبرى
للاتفاق النووي الذي
عقدته الاداره السابقه لان الكونغرس في
الحقيقه الامر لم يوافق على كل
البروتوكولات الخاصه بهذه الاتفاقيه وليس
هنالك عمليات تحقق بالنسبه لوكالات
الاسلحه الدوليه ان ايران تلتزم بها انظر
الى المجمع العسكري في بارش هنالك الكثير
من القضايا المعقده وليس
هنالك حاجه ايران لا تحتاج ان تكون ملتزمه
بشكل
كبير
لان الجو السياسي كان عدائيا في الحقيقه
الامر بالنسبه لامريكا سترى تغير الكثير
من الاعداد ان اداره ترامب بحاجه الى ان
تكمل كادرها هنالك حوال في حقيقه الكثير
من من المناصب لم يتم ملاها بعد في اداره
ترامب ولهجه الاداره ستراها تتغير نحو
حمايه مصالحها ومصالح شركائها وحلفائها وا
في المنطقه
وايضا ستقوم بدعم وتام
الم بعد الفاصل سنناقش باذن الله حدود
تصدي واشنطن لما تصفه بالتهديدات
والتعديات الايرانيه في الشرق الاوسط نرجو
ان تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا
اهلا بكم مجددا في هذه الحلقه التي تناقش
تحذير واشنطن من اقتراب طهران من تحقيق ما
سمته هلالا شيعيا في المنطقه وتاكيدها
اعداد استراتيجيه لمواجهه ما وصفتها
بالتحديات الايرانيه دكتور حسن احمداني من
طهران اليست ايران بما تفعله في المنطقه
سواء ما فعلته في العراق ما فعلته في
الموصل كما قال السيد بومبيو بوجود
ميليشيات شيعيه في الموصل ما تفعله في
سوريا ما تفعله في لبنان سابقا والان ما
تفعله في اليمن هي من تدعو دول المنطقه
الى الدفع بهذه العلاقه العربيه الايرانيه
الى هذا المستوى من
التوتر
طيب يعني المشكله انه هذه ايضا ما الدول
التي ذكرتها هي دول ايضا ذات سياده لها
نخب تحكمها او لا فيها اختلافات لايران لا
لا يعني هذه هذه الدول لها علاقات مع
ايران شاءت السعوديه ام ابد شاءت الولايات
متحده ام ابد ايران لها علاقات اقليميه مع
هذه
الدولس
المغالطه ح العراق اليس هناك بعض المغالطه
العراق دوله احتلت وسلمت لايران افغانستان
دوله احتلت وفتحت لايران سوريا هناك ازمه
بين الشعب وبين رئيس وتدخلت ايران للابقاء
على هذا الرئيس رغما عن شعبه وبالتالي لا
نتكلم عن دول طبيعيه وبالتالي علاقه
طبيعيه هذه ليست مشكله ايران انها ليست
الول طبيعيه الولايات المتحده حليف
السعوديه واسرائيل الرئيسيه هي التي احتلت
العراق وافغانستان الكلام عن تسليم العراق
وافغانستان لايران هو هو المغالطه اساسا
ايران لها حلفاء الاغلبيه في العراق حلفاء
ايران هناك الكثير من حلفاء ايران في
افغانستان ما معنى هل تريد ايران ان
تستغني عن حلفائها ان تترك حلفائها لكي
ترضى عنها مثلا الرياض بشكل طائفي واشنطن
هذا لن يحدث لانه لايران نفوذ اقليمي ليس
ليس طائفي الطائفيه اضفت على النفوذ
الايراني في المنطقه لكي يحدد مستوى نفوذ
ايران ووفق بالمناسبه الى حد كبير هذا
الخطاب الطائفي في تقزيم نفوذ ايران في
بعض المناحي لكنه ايضا ازاد من قوتها في
بعض المناحي الاخرى التي يتكلمون عنها
الان في الرياض و
واشنطن استاذ ماجد فيما يتعلق بهذه
الاشكاليه هذا التطور الحديث عن
استراتيجيه امريكيه مع دول المنطقه من اجل
وقف هذا التمدد لما سمي بالهلال الشيعي
الذي كما قال المسؤول الامريكي بانه قارب
على الاكتمال هل نحن امام استراتيجيه
واضحه المعالم وما هي
خطوطها ام طبعا قبل قبل ما نتحدث عن هل
هناك استراتيجيه ولا لا ان يجب ان نضع
الامور على صابها الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يج تتحمل المسؤوليه كامله هي
التي اوصلت الامر الى هذا الحد وليس فتره
اوباما الديمقراطيين فترتين رئاس بل بل
جورج بوش الابن الجمهوريين والذين استمروا
فتره طويله في الحكم والتحرك في المنطقه
سواء من تحرير الكويت الى احتلال العراق
2003 الجمهوريون ومن بعدهم الديمقراطيين
هم الذين احدثوا هذا الخلل في المنطقه هم
الذين مكنوا ايران ويجب ان تتحمل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه مسؤوليه الخطا الذي
وقعت فيه واصلت فيه المنطقه الى هذه
المرحله هذا اولا ثانيا اشكاليه
الاستراتيجيه غير واضحه يعني الان لا يمكن
ان نتحدث في المنطقه دون ان نستحضر ملفين
متماثلين ملف العراق الذي الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وملف سوريا الذي تديره
روسيا ونعرف ان هناك غرف عمليات مشتركه
للتنسيق بين الجانبين وهناك اتصال يومي
بين وزارتي الدفاع والخارجيه الامريكيه
والروسيه اذا اين الاستراتيجيه يعني هنا
هنا حقيقه السؤال بمعنى انا اريد ان اصل
الى النقطه انه يجب ان لا تبنى هذه
الاستراتيجيه على استنزاف دول الخليج من
اجل تصحيح هذا الخطا الي وقعت في الاداره
الامريكيه بمعنى يجب ان تتحمل الاداره
الامريكيه مسؤوليتها وهذا لا يعني ان دول
الخليج لن تتحرك لان هذا في النهايه يحقق
الامن الخليجي انا اريد فقط اذا تسمح لي
في نص دقيقه ارجع لزميلنا في طهران اقل لو
تكرم نعم هو لم يتحدث على قضيه علاقات
ايران وامتداداتها يقصد طبعا الطائفيه
الجانب الطائفي الشيعي هو يجب ان يتذكر
حاجه واحده فقط انا اشير ل لها ان 48% فقط
من الديمغرافيه الايرانيه هي فارسيه يجب
ان لا ينسى عنده 28 مليون ادر بيجاني
احتلت ايران اراضيهم والشعب اذربيجاني هل
سيعيد الاذربيجاني الى اذربيجان الجمهوريه
المجاوره فقط لنبقى في موضوع الحلقه لانه
الوقت لا يسمح ل بالاسترسال في موضوعات
كهذه طيب ضيفي مايكل ددي لروسو عندما
يتكلم اداره الرئيس ترامب عن وجود
استراتيجيه لمواجهه ما سمته بالهلال
الشيعي
كيف تكون هذه المواجهه كما قال ضيفي من
طهران ايران موجوده في العراق بالاتفاق مع
الاغلبيه موجوده في سوريا مع رئيس الى
الان هو موجود موجوده في لبنان من خلال
اتفاق سياسي في لبنان موجوده الان في
اليمن بحكم الامر الواقع ايضا في ظل
انقلاب حدث في ايضا في اليمن ماذا عن
معالم هذه
الاستراتيجيه ترنا ان داره ترامب ربما
لديها اولويات عليا الان اولها هو
اصلاح العلاقات التحالف التي اضرت بها
اداره اوباما
وايضا التهديد الاساسي الذي يمثله الحرس
الثوري الايراني ربما يمثل التهديد الاكبر
وايضا هنالك حركه اسلاميه عالميه تهدف الى
تدمير الحضاره الغربيه وكما ترى في
بالنسبه للولايات المتح حده والتي ظهر عن
ظهرت من زيارات ملك الاردن والرئيس السيسي
الى واشنطن هم قاموا من مصلحتنا ان
نعيد نعيد الاستقرار الى الشرق الاوسط
وايضا نحاول السيطره على القوى الجموني او
المتفرده وايضا مواجهه النشاطات
الروسيه المزعزع للاستقرار لذلك هي الامر
الكثير فيها الكثير من القضايا
الدبلوماسيه والسياسيه والاقتصاديه وايضا
عمليه
تاكيد تم انكار فيها الحقيقه يجب علينا ان
نتحدث بشكل مباشر مع حلفائنا وبشكل ع
اشكرك ادرك ان الوقت كنت معنا مايكل ديل
روسو وكبير الباحثين في مركز السياسه
الامنيه وكذلك اشكر ضيفي من طهران الدكتور
حسن احمد يان استاذ دراسات الشرق الاوسط
في جامعه طهران وكذلك ضيفي هنا في
الاستديو ماجد التركي الاكاديمي والمحلل
السياسي السعودي ورئيس مركز الاعلام
والدراسات العربيه الروسيه شكرا جزيلا لك
اذا اتي لنهايه هذهه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه
جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء
ه